FUNDRAISING RECEPTION TONIGHT
WITH POLITICAL DONORS.
>> Bill: NEWT GINGRICH, FORMER
HOUSE SPEAKER.
THANKS FOR COMING BACK.
ABC, "WASHINGTON POST."
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUES AMONG
AMERICANS AND VOTERS.
ECONOMY AT 84%.
THAT TO CHEW ON.
IN THE FACE OF THIS INFLATION
NUMBER.
NOT A LOT OF TIME TO MAKE UP FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WHEN
ELECTION IS RIGHT AROUND THE
CORNER.
>> WELL, THE PROBLEM IS A MAN
WHO WORKS WITH ME CAME IN
YESTERDAY MORNING.
HE STOPPED BY THE PICK UP FOUR
HOT DOGS AND PAID OVER $7 AND
WAS JUST SAYING YOU AREN'T GOING
TO BE ABLE TO SELL THIS TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I THINK GALLUP HAS REPORTED THE
LARGEST REPUBLICAN ADVANTAGE ON
THE ECONOMY SINCE 1946, WHICH
WAS A LANDSLIDE FOR THE
CONGRESSIONAL REPUBLICANS.
I THINK THAT THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN KNOWS EVERY TIME THEY
GO TO THE GAS STATION,
CALIFORNIA IS PROJECTED MAY GET
TO $8 A GALLON BECAUSE IT'S THE
MOST EXPENSIVE GAS IN THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE OF STATE LAWS.
EVERY TIME THEY GO TO BUY
SOMETHING AT THE GROCERY STORE,
EVERY TIME THEY DEAL WITH SUPPLY
CHAIN GETTING SOMETHING FOR
THEIR HOUSE, THIS AIN'T WORKING.
JOE BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS BEAR
THE BURDEN.
THEY HAVE THE HOUSE, SENATE,
WHITE HOUSE AND IT AIN'T
WORKING.
I THINK PERSONALLY I THINK YOU
WILL SEE A TSUNAMI.
VIRTUALLY EVERYBODY WHO IS
UNDECIDED WILL BREAK FOR THE
REPUBLICANS.
IF YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT AND BELOW
53 OR 54%, YOU ARE VERY LIKELY
GOING TO LOSE COME ELECTION DAY.
>> Dana: INTERESTING THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN TOLD JAKE TAPPER
THIS WEEK HE THINKS THAT
REPUBLICANS DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
TO RUN ON.
LISTEN TO THIS.
IS
>> YOU THINK DEMOCRATS HAVE
SOMETHING TO RUN ON?
>> President Biden: WHAT'S THE
REPUBLICAN PLATFORM TO RUN ON?
WHAT ARE THEY FOR?
THEY WANT TO PUT SOCIAL SECURITY
ON THE CHOPPING BLOCK EVERY FIVE
YEARS AND THE OTHER LEADER COMES
ALONG AND SAYS NO, EVERY YEAR UP
FOR GRABS.
MEDICARE, MEDICAID.
THESE AREN'T NEGLIGENT ABLE
ITEMS IN TERMS OF WHETHER YOU'LL
CONTINUE THEM OR NOT.
>> Dana: HOW SHOULD REPUBLICANS
RESPOND TO THAT?
>> LOOK, I CARRY AROUND WITH ME
KEVIN MCCARTHY'S HOUSE
REPUBLICAN COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA.
YOU CAN GO TO COMMIT TO
AMERICA.COM.
THERE ARE 150 SPECIFIC POLICY
PROPOSALS, MANY OF WHICH JOE
BIDEN WOULD NOT LIKE TO SEE GET
TO THE WHITE HOUSE DESK BUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WOULD LIKE IT.
SO TO SUGGEST THAT REPUBLICANS
DON'T HAVE SOMETHING TO RUN ON.
SENATOR MCCONNELL, THE SENATE
REPUBLICAN LEADER AND RICK SCOTT
HAVE BOTH ENDORSED THE CONCEPTS
OF A COMMITMENT TO AMERICA.
I THINK THERE IS A HUGE GAP
BETWEEN THE FAILURE OF THE BIDEN
TEAM, THE FAILURE OF THE
DEMOCRATS, AND THE FACT THAT ALL
THEY HAVE LEFT IS TO ATTACK AND
FRANKLY LIE.
THEY LIED ABOUT AFGHANISTAN,
THEY'VE LIED ABOUT THE ECONOMY,
THEY'VE LIED ABOUT INFLATION,
THEY'VE LIED ABOUT THE BORDER.
SO OF COURSE THEY WILL LIE ABOUT
REPUBLICANS.
THAT'S THE HALLMARK OF THEIR
CAMPAIGN.
>> Bill: IT ALMOST FEELS EVERY
DAY YOU CAN SENSE THE ELECTION
SHIFTING A LITTLE BIT.
YOU MAY BE RIGHT.
YOU COULD SEE THE TSUNAMI YOU
TALKED ABOUT.
GO AHEAD.
>> WELL, BILL, THE WAY I'VE
LIVED THROUGH A SERIES OF THESE,
1974, 1980, 1994, 2010, STARTING
AROUND LABOR DAY, THE MOMENTUM
STARTS GROWING AND GROWING AND
GROWING.
THE REASON IS DOESN'T MATTER
WHAT THE TV ADS SAY OR WHAT YOU
AND I SAY, PEOPLE WHO ARE OUT IN
THEIR OWN LIVES, THEY EXPERIENCE
THE FAILURE AND THEY FINALLY
SAY, WHETHER IT'S WATCHING CRIME
ON THE EVENING NEWS, BEING
AFRAID TO GO ON THE SUBWAY IN
NEW YORK, AS PEOPLE NOW TELL ME
THEY ARE, THE WHOLE PROCESS,
PEOPLE IN THEIR OWN LIVES.
THIS IS WHY, FRANKLY, HERSCHEL
WALKER WILL WIN AND OZ IS GOING
TO WIN.
70% OF PEOPLE IN PHILADELPHIA
SAY CRIME IS THE BIGGEST ISSUE.
THEY ARE LOSING THEM ON CRIME,
THEY ARE LOSING THEM ON THE
BOARD ARE AND 100,000 AMERICANS
DYING FROM DRUG OVERDOSES AS
FENTANYL POURS INTO THE COUNTRY.
THEY ARE LOSING THEM ON THE FACT
KAMALA HARRIS TO GO ON
TELEVISION TO SAY THE BORDER IS
SECURE IS A JOKE.
PEOPLE -- IT'S A TRAGIC JOKE.
YOU SAW THIS HAPPEN IN THE
DEBATE IN THE SENATE IN OHIO
WHERE TIM RYAN WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE RAPE OF A YOUNG GIRL AND
VANCE POINTED OUT SHE WAS RAPED
BY AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT AND RYAN
VOTED AGAINST CON TROLLING THE
BORDER TIME AFTER TIME.
IF THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN HERE SHE
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN RAPED.
PEOPLE HAVE THE SENSE STUFF IS
ALL OUT OF CONTROL.
THEY CAN'T TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT
IT AND THEY'RE YOUNG UP ON
THINGS LIKE TRANSGENDER ISSUES
WHEN MOST OF US WANT OUR KIDS TO
BE SAFE, GO TO A SCHOOL THAT
SUCCEEDS.
YOU SAW YESTERDAY THE WORST
RESULTS ON COLLEGE TESTS IN 30
YEARS.
SO I THINK PEOPLE GENERALLY
THINK THE SYSTEM IS NOT WORKING
RIGHT NOW.
>> Dana: MR. SPEAKER, THANK YOU.
26 DAYS TO GO.
WE'LL BE IN TOUCH WITH YOU AND
LOOKS LIKE THINGS LOOK GOOD FO